entrò al futuro con la determinazione
non soltanto di credere alle nuove idee
di fuggire
e chi è
e oggi condivido con voi una storia è
un'idea la mia storia comincia nel 71
sono nato quell'anno ed è stato
distribuito commercialmente il
videogioco pong quella lì vicina e mia
sorella gioca anche lei con i robot
perché le sue bambole stranamente sono
tutte rotte ero io che prelevava tutti i
meccanismi elettrici motorini e cedere
poi ci facevo i miei esperimenti a 10
anni ho avuto il primo computer zx
spectrum 48 kilobyte di memoria ram e mi
sono reso conto però già a quel primo
impatto che il computer è un'estensione
della vento vana se usato bene e questo
lo stiamo vedendo sempre di più nei
nostri giorni quando già portiamo in
tasca un mega computer ormai questo è il
giorno del mio diciassettesimo
compleanno e presentava una festa di
paese faceva il dj nei locali turistici
windsurf body building
un ragazzo di quell'età non potevo
desiderare di più e 26 dicembre
esattamente sei mesi dopo il 26 giugno
dell 89
ho avuto un incidente in moto la morte
della dinamica ma in realtà un incidente
avvenuto a 45 chilometri orari un
trattore in una piccola strada guidato
da una persona senza patente e senza
assicurazione
me lo sono ritrovato frullato adesso
della mia carreggiata in curva
andavo così piano che sono riuscita ad
infilarmi tra la curva e il trattore ma
dietro aveva un imballatori per il fieno
molte più grande e quindi mi sono
ritrovato il muro in curva
cosa è successo che si sono strappati i
nervi del braccio sinistro a causa del
casco il casto mi ha salvato la vita
però nello stesso tempo aumentando il
peso della testa ha fatto da elastico
intenzione
il problema del braccio sinistro mai
vissuto fin dal giorno zero è stato
praticamente naturale per me fare tutto
con una mano dai lacci delle scarpe la
cravatta eccetera anzi a quattro mesi
dell'incidente è ancora 17 anni mi sono
trasferito da sopra prova a fare
l'università passettino indietro
l'incidente è avvenuto mentre facevo gli
esami di maturità ho fatto gli iscritti
in classe e gli orali in ospedale con
tutta la commissione attorno la mia
insegnante di lettere con la lacrimuccia
hai potuto essere originale fino
all'ultimo
il mio problema però è un altro è un
mostro invisibile con cui convivo da 23
anni ormai il cervello manda segnali
ancora di stimolo e di movimento al
braccio che però sono interrotti al
livello del midollo spinale e quindi
come in un corto circuito
tornano al cervello sotto forma di
impulsi di dolore per avvisarlo come ha
bisogno di qualcosa che non va e questa
è una cosa che dura da 23 anni senza un
secondo l'interruzione sono dolori molto
forti anche adesso mentre vi parlo
la sensazione esattamente di un braccio
addormentato però invece di avere quel
formicolio fastidioso sono come scosse
elettriche tagli futuri di spilli
eccetera sono dolori così forti che mi
hanno portato a fare circa 17 interventi
chirurgici nel tentativo di rimuovere le
ho avuto l'onore di essere anche un
cyborg ante litteram portando nel mio
midollo spinale elettrodi chip che
sarebbero serviti in teoria a ingannare
il cervello e dargli quel quello stimolo
che non aveva più dal basso ma non sono
servite a niente
hanno solo peggiorato tantissimo le cose
lungo intervento dovuto nel 98 un
intervento di 12 ore che mi ha
praticamente piegato in due e non è
servito a niente quindi sono tornato a
casa distrutto non vedevo perché con
quel tipo di dolore anche i farmaci ed
era la nonna non mi consentiva neanche
di pensare che anche di parlare e quindi
ho scoperto che se potevo stare un
pochino seduto su una sedia era meglio
non guardare la tv ma dedicarsi al
computer e ci sono ritornato da quando
era un bambino diciamo a questa a questa
passione e quando ho ripreso il computer
era appena esploso internet e quindi la
la visione precedente che io avevo della
macchina concludere è cambiata
notevolmente sia a livello di stimolo
mentale e sia soprattutto il pensiero
magico di essere tutti connessi di poter
condividere le cose anche se adesso su
facebook si condividono i cattivi ma
passerà anche quello spero e da lì
allora ho iniziato a lavorare come
designer prevalentemente a casa e piano
piano diciamo la mia professionalità e
aumentata si è cresciuta e nel 2004 ho
provato un farmaco che a parità di
effetti collaterali che dava il meno
rispetto al precedente mi dava lo stesso
tipo di copertura dal dolore tra l'altro
i farmaci che prende ora ricoprono il 20
quando va bene il 30 per cento del
dolore totale il resto tocca a gestirlo
a me quotidianamente e quando ho preso
questo farmaco nuovo il mio cervello e
risorto perché ho ripreso un possesso
delle mie facoltà mentali
la prima cosa che ho fatto è stata è
andato a tadino a fare un master anche
se non ero laureato master divinando in
digital entertainment e vi sono salito
anche di interesse occupandomi di
videogames sono andato a milano a
lavorare per una società
l'unica società italiana diciamo che
sviluppa videogiochi con una
distribuzione internazionale
e qui vorrei fare una piccola parentesi
per farvi vedere che cos'è un videogioco
oggi
e assolutamente cinematografico e quindi
questo ci dà l'opportunità di creare un
nuovo video che a metà tra la realtà
virtuale
la cinematografia e l'interazione nel
frattempo siccome la vita non tiene in
considerazione se stai bene se stai male
mia madre ha avuto un tumore al seno e
nell'ultimo intervento chirurgico è
coinciso il mio con il suo quindi a un
certo punto io ricoverato in ospedale
ho chiesto l'utilizzo dell'ambulanza per
andare a trovare lei che avevano al
trono dopo la sua morte un anno dopo
sono tornato in calabria stare un
pochino con mio padre li ho riscoperto
tante cose e forse erano quelle da cui
era fuggito a dare al ragazzo la
lentezza della vita eccetera e che li
abbia apprezzato a ho visto però posti
stupendi il giardino del mediterraneo
però incuria totale se le cose fatte
senza amore ed io ho cominciato a
mettere insieme tutto diciamo quello che
era il bagaglio della mia esperienza che
poi si è approfondito anche con la
realtà virtuale perché ho fatto anche
delle considerazioni umane noi siamo
capaci di queste meraviglie ma purtroppo
anche di queste atrocità che speravamo
di aver legato al suo team bianco e nero
e invece purtroppo le ritroviamo oggi
ancora tra noi
oggi anche abbastanza facile fare la
critica della società abbiamo questa
crisi economica in pieno svolgimento
fonti di potere per la maggior parte
corrotte comunque con interessi
conseguenza sul nostro stile di vita che
noi non vediamo come reazione immediata
la terra li avverte tanti movimenti come
questi attuali degli indignados
la realtà è che comunque c'è un gruppo
di oligarchi finanziaria che fare il
bello e il cattivo tempo del mondo
quindi io credo che noi adulti non
possiamo cambiare il mondo
i nostri eroi quelli che riusciranno a
creare questo molto saranno loro sarà
un'intera generazione di problem solvers
che riusciranno attraverso i mezzi
digitali ad imparare come collaborare
cooperare però ancora ci troviamo di
fronte ad una realtà molto limitata
perché l'insegnamento in tutto il mondo
è ancora quello tradizionale adatto in
epoca industriale quindi una conoscenza
nozionistica la punizione delle proprie
ora invece siamo in piena era digitale
lì le bare bianche sono quelle che gli
studenti hanno appreso per via
tradizionale sullo stesso argomento
un'altra classe che li ha presi per via
digitale
i risultati sono del 40 per cento in più
con la realtà virtuale invece si aumenta
ancora addirittura il 98 per cento della
ritenzione degli argomenti perché
cattura immerge questa è la parola
chiave
l'immersione ho scoperto anche perché
qualche tempo fa perché c'è questa parte
più antica del nostro cervello
l'amigdala che contiene gli istinti
primordiali dell'uomo quando noi ci
troviamo in una situazione di stress
quindi può essere anche di
interrogazione scolastica il cervello va
nel panico e sceglie il fight or flight
cioè se combattendo fuggire
e in quel momento tutti quelli che sono
gli stimoli neurologici vanno persi
noi abbiamo anche una cultura stupenda
che tutti nel mondo utilizzano per
produrre delle opere interattive
cinematografiche di altissimo
valore e noi invece le apprezziamo quasi
non ci rendiamo neanche corto e allora
la mia idea è di reagire alla crisi
economica attraverso il call call
entertainment è una mia definizione che
non è quella di virtual heritage cioè di
conservazione dei beni culturali ma è
renderli aa.vv attraverso personaggi
olografici attraverso dei percorsi di
storie e di reagire a quello che
l'insegnamento tradizionale con tutta
una serie di nuovi strumenti che sono
gli studi sul cervello nuove metodologie
pedagogiche che tengono incontro
l'adattamento anche che il nostro
cervello sta avendo perché noi adesso
abbiamo sviluppato molto di più un
intelligenza visuale abbiamo sviluppato
il multitasking però per contro ci dà
una storia di attenzione molto più bassa
non riusciamo a concentrarci per molto
tempo sulla stessa cosa
quindi è importante io tutto questo l'ho
realizzato concettualizzato in un
progetto di parco tecnologico un parto
totalmente dedicato a questo tipo di
tecnologie in cui si usano non solo
serbia insegnare ma anche per fare
business perché questo tipo di
tecnologie può essere applicato in
qualsiasi campo dell'attività umana
medicina difesa intrattenimento
educazione il video è molto bello però
non dura tanto insomma ci sono
tantissimi esempi di come si può
utilizzare questa tecnologia e non vuole
essere concentrato solo su quel tipo di
tecnologia ma anche su quella che viene
definita la singolarità cioè il fatto
che in questo momento c'è
un'accelerazione della conoscenza e che
ci sono dei campi particolari come la
bioingegneria le neuro tecnologie che da
un momento all'altro potrebbero darci
dei risultati incredibili che possono
cambiare il destino
dell'essere umano e di cui noi non
possiamo prevedere assolutamente nulla
quindi il futuro si basa su due cose 1 è
quella di cercare di prepararci
cognitivamente e due è quello di agire
per modificarlo in prima persona più si
agisce e più c'è la probabilità che quel
futuro diventi una realtà
questa è un'attrazione che ho realizzato
sempre concettualmente per i ragazzi
delle scuole primarie secondarie in cui
praticamente hanno una narrativa che li
porta alla colonizzazione di un altro
pianeta simile alla terra dove loro però
devono reinventare completamente il modo
in cui noi viviamo cioè il modo in cui
si lavora in cui il mondo in cui si
punisce o comunque si tratta chi
commette crimini visione diciamo
derivata dalla loro interazione per poi
magari buttare questi risultati ad
organismi trans nazionali come la
comunità europea l'onu e fargli vedere
le soluzioni che anche abbastanza non
solo ingegnose ma anche molto naturali
diciamo
i ragazzi io vorrei partecipare al ted
prize 2014 che si aprirà ad aprile del
con questa proposta di coordinare
un'azione globale per riformate
l'educazione dei ragazzi e prepararli al
futuro grazie